I want to congratulate you because when
I first met you struggling you were
you're doing your show when I first met
you
where was your show public access public
access television yeah I met you and you
were doing very creative things and I
thought I like this guy we had you on
the show you were terrific now you've
blown up now you your promotion your
billboards are everywhere everywhere I
go in Los Angeles I see your face
this means that you've got real people
behind you and there's a lot of
excitement yeah they're spending some
money on it now which is nice that
change from public access certainly yeah
it's weird for me that those are
everywhere that cuz I live in New York
they're on the subways too so I see them
I see posters of my own head every day
yeah cuz I'm like successful and I'm now
that I have subway ads but I'm not
successful enough that I don't have to
take the subway I take this so you're
standing there next to your face yeah
and how do people react to that well I
live in Queens where no one's in the
mood for anyone fancy so I feel them
getting mad yeah no one's like oh it's
that guy it's like oh it's that guy like
I know that every day yeah also weird
cuz you can't you can't control the
other subway ads oh the ads they put you
near yeah and there's been some weird
ones
yeah this is unfortunate I think you
took this picture this is really we
didn't do this that is real that is
horrifying
yeah and it's also like just a more
eye-catching ad yeah but I also I will
say I don't mind cuz I agree syphilis is
serious everybody gotta watch out there
I'm all for sexual freedom but please
keep it safe yeah watch your backs
yeah he's smart yeah so I'm glad that
you work that into your stick
but you know you had a friend who also
saw your ad but the context was a little
awkward and took a picture can you
explain what that is before yes at a
friend in Los Angeles send me a picture
of a billboard and it was next to
something very specific it was above if
you want to show that show it is on fire
yeah and then if you look at the
graffiti it says the word fail which
sort of sums up my life and career
no it does it yes it does you know in
your heart that it's true no do you ever
worry that I know that the times that
I've had a subway ad or an ad that was
readily accessible I've been just
thinking like oh you know someone's
gonna draw penises all over I I want I
want as much penis John on my head as as
the world can muster I feel like it's
part of a New York tradition to see it
get vandalize I've seen some good ones
I've seen big 666 across my forehead a
lot of them did they just draw on the
forehead this is a lot of ample
territory yeah someone actually removed
my eye from one of them and that creeped
me out that's scary
yeah I don't know what they need my eye
for yeah the best one though and I
challenge anyone out there to top this I
really do if you're in New York or
anywhere where you see an ad vandalize
it I love it I think it's funny please
do vandalize my subway ask someone did
write across my forehead the words me
daddy
well there you go hey everybody
you